[Musik]
ein Arzt ein Arzt Schlitten Unfall
ziehen Sie sich bitte eine
Wartenummer beim Christbaum schlagen die
Axt ins Bein gehauen ziehen sie sich
eine Wartenummer seit wann haben wir
Wartenummer haben wir nicht aber solange
die suchen wo man eine herbekommt da
kann ich wenigstens mal in Ruhe meine
Tasse Tee trinken in diesem
Irrenhaus
num
mal alles wird
gut servus ich bin der
Bonz der Bonz aus popofik in Serbien leg
mich in die Arsch woher kennst du
popofik na das steht ja in den
Unterlagen ah und wer bist du bist du
die DR hirschusen weil du hast Hirsch
auf die Kopf ja ein bisschen
Weihnachtsstimmung wenn man schon den
ganzen Heiligabend hier verbringen muss
also darf ich habe überhaupt keine Bock
mehr auf Weihnachten feiert man in
Serbien überhaupt Weihnachten keine
Ahnung aber in bobofi kleine
scheißdrecksskff in Serbien da feiert
man Weihnachten dreiheilige König
Silvester und Nikolaus eine einzige
Vormittag da stellt dir dann für den
Nikolaus die Stiefel raus habe ich
einmal gemacht hat der drcoo die Stiefel
geklaut die alte saudreck [__]
[__] sagst du nicht zu mir obwohl
von mir aus ich habe den Drago gemeint
ach du kennst Drago die alte
weiberschmecker also jetzt mal was ganz
anderes also was fehlt ihnen eigentlich
in den Unterlagen steht gar nichts mir
fehlt die Ruhe weil meine
Schwiegermutter ist zu besucht die alte
Schabracke und die geht mich sowas von
auf die ja sie sind verheiratet nein
warum ja weil sie eine Schwiegermutter
haben
im alle haben Schwiegermutter sogar
schon die kleine Kinder haben
Schwiegermutter Scheiße hallo hallo
hören sie mich hallo ja himb und hen
deine Bratzen weg und zwar schneell geht
s gut wie viele Finger sehen sie ja GLE
weniger wenn es weiter V
Gesichter ja gut aber woher kommt denn
das ganze Blut haben sie in der
Schneidemaschine gelangt wo für Blut ach
so das ist eine Kirschsoße als Rosin hat
den leff im Mixer vergessen das rimpfig
und jetzt hat den ganzen Mixer
zuissen da fehlt
ingwa
stimmt ich doch nicht selber drauf bin
ich bin gleich wieder da da draußen da
braucht jemand dringend
etwas und zwar
ich haben sie mal
Feuer raus vom Zimmer komme ich her und
ich muss euch sagen das Bier ist gleich
her Herr Bamberger gehen sie wieder
zurück ich komme gleich zum Infusion
tauschen jawoh aber dann B ein G und
nicht wieder diese f die brü ja ich
schau mal was ich machen
kann morgen Kinder wir
wasraau mir wird ganz schwarz vor die
Auge ich glaube ich sterbe
tot hallo
Aufwachen ja verdammte scheißentrick
richt wie Weihnachtsessen in Poof sie
können jetzt gehen
weiß nicht ich glaube lieber nicht ich
bleib noch mal über Nacht weiß wegen
Beobachtung im bobofi gibt es schönne
Sprichwort das sagt sicher ist sicher
das sagen wir hier auch oh das ist schön
das ist wie schlagen zwei Herzen in eine
Takt ich Stö ja nur ungern aber
vielleicht kommst jetzt zu mir rüberel
also so reden sie fei nicht mit
mir
nicht wer ich bin ich bin der Joel
Sternekoch vom le
vor gleich ums Eck da hatten wir letzte
Woche Weihnachtsfeier und nach der Feier
hatten wir alle wieder Dienst und
plötzlich war die ganze Notaufnahme voll
mit uns selbst welcher Jahrgang war den
ihr war seibling das war r die war sch
die hat dies seibling verwechselt hat
die mit dem D weil muss
wochhängen was ganz anderes was haben
Sie eigentlich
[Musik]
vor
sprachnachrichtauf wie mus noch Ofen
bleiben war oder
[Musik]
Stunden
einatmen
ausatmen
Einatmen sternmann brauchst du flache
Blutdruck du jetzt meine auf da drüben
dann kommüber kriegst du se drum [__]
von mir hier kriegt keiner von niemand
[__] wir sind alle schön friedlich es
ist Weihnachten verdammte scheiße ich
schmeiß euch hier gleich alle raus alle
klar verstanden ja ist ja schon recht
servus du hast Moment Zeit für mich
schleauer jetzt
bin sie warten bitte
draußenren nicht der Puls ist normal
erstaunlicherweise scheur ich bra zum
Essen sie Wiener mit Kartoffelsalat
Wiener mit
Kartoffelsalat ke schlechte Idee also
dann nimme 200 Mal Wiener mit
Kartoffelsalat aber schön einpacken ja
kack 200 Mal Ente oder 200 Mal Würstel
mit Kartoffelsalat das ist do wurcht
kommen Sie denn darauf dass Sie unser
Krankenhaus Essen bekommen was sonst ich
k do sonst ng meh was ich komm umbring
komm aufh geh ins Wasser aber vergiss
die Badehose nicht
was auf Sterne Kochmann habe ich Idee
meine Schwiegermutter die kocht immer
für ganze Dorf heute
gibt lang locker für 200 Leute schlimmer
als der ING seibling kann nicht werden
ma ich dir g Preis ja gut dann von mir
aus dann aber auf geht's geh
mal servus gittelfraau alle Gute für
dich
ber Halleluja und und jetzt mal ganz
kurz stille
Nacht
Aufstieg der war ja auch noch
da
und was fehlt ihnen mir mir fät
überhaupt nichts aber meine Kühe
verstehst meine K die haben s so
übertrieben mitm K fressen und mit
glüwshaufer die hab meen dünch die SAS
ich mein Lebtag noch nicht
[Musik]
gesehen warum
ich der Tier schon
zT Mul miulli Mulli K re warm
[Musik]
herin